Speaker 1: One of the difficulties right now
of running against Donald Trump in a Republican
primary is that if you go completely anti MAGA,
there may not be enough Republicans in the party
for you to win the primary. But if you go MAGA in
facing off against Trump, well why would somebody
vote for your MAGA when the MAGA guy is actually
running? And this is the problem that Ron DeSantis
donors are now identifying. Fascinating article in
Business Insider. DeSantis Mega-Donors of Revolt
in private Chat saying if they wanted a MAGA
candidate, they would donate to Trump, according
to this report. Really, really interesting stuff.
A group of wealthy desanctis donors criticized
him in a private chat. Rolling Stone obtained
screenshots of the group chat between Republican
mega-donors earlier this week. A wealthy Florida
donor publicly said he'd changed his mind about
financially supporting DeSantis. This is the
latest indication that the Florida governor's
wealthy supporters are starting to revolt with
a Republican mega-donor recently going public
about no longer wanting to support to financially
support. DeSantis is yet to be announced campaign.
The screenshots reveal these wealthy
Republican donors questioning the
governor's chances of beating former President
Donald Trump in a Republican primary. They're
correct to be doing that. The polling is
an absolute disaster for DeSantis. Lately,
a series of recent political missteps, including
continuing with his out-of-state publicity
tour. While massive flooding took place in Fort
Lauderdale appear to have enraged these donors,
Rolling Stone reported. Responding to the Fort
Lauderdale incident, the media outlet said one
donor wrote What the f is wrong with Ardi? Another
donor asked who in the group could reach DeSantis
the quickest to complain about it. Several other
donors were furious that the governor referred
to Russia's invasion of Ukraine as a, quote,
territorial dispute, with one calling on DeSantis
to walk back the comment. DeSantis did later go
back on the comment after receiving criticism,
according to a Rolling Stone source familiar with
the communication. The donor who called for the
walk back wrote a livid response. The source said,
quote, My understanding is that the message was if
we wanted an F-ing MAGA candidate, we would donate
to Donald Trump. Other donors wrote They wanted
the Santos to hit back harder at Trump, with
one describing him as a damn wimp. This is this
is just delightful. Okay, so there's a couple of
different things going on here. Yes. DeSantis has
obsessed himself with expanding the Don't Say
gay bill, which we will talk about on today's
bonus show, the Disney stuff, the Anti-woke stuff,
etc.. He also is alienating Florida mega-donors
by leaving Florida and selling books in South
Carolina and Chicago and wherever else he's been
while Florida is having actual problems. Now, the
issue there's a couple of different issues here
to talk about. It could be argued, and I believe
it could be argued accurately, that if you really
want to do something different in the Republican
Party right now, it's not DeSantis that you need
to turn to. Really, it's like Mitt Romney or even
further away Liz Cheney. Now, I'm not saying that
the Republican Party right now has enough people
in it who actually want to get away from MAGA and
would go for something like Romney or Liz Cheney.
I don't know that that's the case. And in fact,
it very well may not be. The problem with the
sand is, is that the sand is too maga. He frames
himself as sort of like the reasonable MAGA. The
effective MAGA. The MAGA who won't get himself
in trouble because of the lack of decorum that
Trump has, or whatever the case may be. But that's
a really difficult situation for Republicans,
because with Trump under indictment and yet still
in a commanding lead in the Republican primary,
but mostly losing to Biden in hypothetical general
election polls, which may still change. If you're
Ron DeSantis, you're in the situation of, well,
I'm going to be like Trump, but better. You can't
beat Trump at MAGA. You just can't. Even if it's
accurate, that DeSantis would be more effective
at MAGA because he wouldn't get himself into as
many self-inflicted problems as Trump did. You
can't out MAGA the MAGA guy, so that's not going
to work. If you say I denounce Trump altogether,
including Trump ism and all of the things that are
wrapped up with MAGA right now, at least based on
the polling we're seeing, you can't actually beat
Trump in a primary right now. So it's really
quite a circumstance between a rock and a hard
place. You could say that the Republican Party
finds itself today, and this is what happens
when you choose the rage voters, as I explained
yesterday. They created anger, fear, voting,
and they blew it up to historic proportions
recently. We didn't just find ourselves randomly
in a situation where conservative voters are angry
and also misinformed. The misinformed anger has
been a strategy for the Republican Party. Once
they realize they can't win on policy anymore
and this goes back a long time, you could go
back. I mean, if you read waves of rancor,
which is a really good book, maybe out of print
now, you will learn about how a lot of this
started in the early AM radio talk radio era, so
on and so forth and so Desantis's broader problem
is you can't out maga maga, but if you denounce
MAGA, it's not clear you can win. The narrower
problem over the last month or two is he just
won't move on. He's sticking with don't say gay,
he's sticking with trans he's sticking with Disney
and he's sticking with Anti-woke. Trump would have
moved on to the next thing by now. And it's not
like Trump's political instincts are necessarily
perfect by any means. But Trump would have, either
by accident or by advice from people around him or
by instinct, moved on to something new. DeSantis
is sticking with these issues on which he is
actually losing not only many of the voters, but
also his donors. This is going to be a fascinating
campaign. I love the complete crash and burn of
it. And I'm also aware that there's a strategic
component which is like, who would we rather Biden
face? Based on the polling we're seeing right now,
we'd rather Biden face Trump if indeed
Biden is going to run for reelection,
which he says he is but has not actually filed
for at this point in time. Let me know your
thoughts. Make sure you have subscribed to the
YouTube channel at YouTube.com slash The David
Pakman Show. What a packed show that I have for
you today. Remember that you can sign up for
membership with The David Pakman Show. Join Pacman
dot com. All sorts of goodies and perks available,
including an extra show every single day.
Commercial free audio and video streams of
the show, the David Pakman show, soundboard on
the website as well as invites to members only
town hall events. Sign up at Join Packman Icon
Coupon Code 24 starts now. Always available to you